what are you up to not up to anything
morty because this isn't real life
it's a promo commercial what are you
talking about Rick's this is real life
and why is your family standing there
all presentable ah I don't know because
they're just as much part of real life
as our adventures adventures why would I
say that talking about our show Morty
because this is a promo commercial try
turning 90 degrees Morty turn to the
side oh my god Rick my body isn't here
this is a promo commercial sorry life
just cruise promo commercial disposable
commercial more
welcome back everyone it's Charlie we
have brand new rick and morty season
4 to break down we got a new promo
and all the episode titles from the five
episodes that are going to be dropping
before the end of the year there's all
kinds of easter eggs you probably
spotted especially in the episode titles
and rick breaking the fourth wall i will
be doing easter egg videos for all the
episodes this year so if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything i'm also doing a merch
giveaway too that I'll talk about at the
end of the video starting with the
footage then talking about the episode
titles Rick breaks the fourth wall
because Morty apparently does not know
that they're inside a commercial and
then surprising turns around and reveals
that nothing is real
inside this promo commercial morty
realizes he's not real than freaks out
Rick's not real in probably Jerry Beth
and summer as well in the background
they kind of look like the low-grade
versions of reality from the M night
Shyamalan episode yes yeah wait yes yes
if you're new to the show
Rick breaks the fourth wall all the time
almost as much as Deadpool does across
the last three seasons he's done it at
least 23 times it was the scene at the
end of the pilot where Rick talks about
WWE and Morty calm which is a website
for the show that was a real website
that Adult Swim made during episode two
lawnmower dog Rick and Morty talk about
what their world would be like if the
species ruled the world they talk about
it in a way that people would talk about
referencing a TV show or movie in real
life referencing Justin roiland dog
world cartoon at the very end of anatomy
Park in episode 3 Rick says are you
people even human what kind of Christmas
is this Jerry looks up from his iPad at
the camera breaking the fourth wall
saying what are you asking me for I'm
just a Jerry at the end of meeseeks and
destroy' Erica looks at the camera and
says goodbye to the viewers in raising
gazorpazorp Rick looks at the camera and
says the plot thickens then later he
also looks at the camera says am irate
ladies and gentlemen he also waves
goodbye to the audience at the end of
the episode again during the very first
interdimensional cable episode they talk
about the improvisational tone of the
episodes of interdimensional cable
referencing the fact that all of the
episodes Justin and Dan completely
improved Mexican Armada brothers who are
just regular brothers running in
fan from an asteroid and all sorts of
things the movie then in the finale Rick
again waves goodbye to the audience
saying thanks for watching during season
two in Total Recall Rick looks to camera
when the room becomes completely
infested it says it looks like a Where's
Waldo page and asked you to try and find
him and says we'll be back right after
the commercial even more direct when
justin roiland as rick is ranting about
Nintendo 3ds turns to camera and says
Nintendo give me free stuff this is
actually based on a real-life rant that
Justin roiland did when he came into the
writers room before season 2 was
completed he came in talking about
Nintendo 3ds is trying to convince the
other crew members in the writers to get
in on the action with him during
interdimensional cable - when they talk
about why they're doing a sequel to the
original he says I don't know we pretty
much nailed it the first time talking
about the original interdimensional
cable episode then during wedding
squatchers we get the fourth ball break
from mr. poopy butthole at the end
because it's the season 2 finale letting
everyone know that it's gonna be a
really long time before season 3 gets
here which it obviously was probably the
most notable fourth ball break at the
beginning of season 3 was in episode 1
Rick shank redemption when he's
screaming about Szechuan sauce in 9 more
seasons a Rick and Morty at the very end
during Morty's Mind blowers he turns to
the camera and tells us the audience
that they're doing this instead of doing
interdimensional cable 3 I could go on
it I could do an entire video just about
the fourth wall breaks the last time he
does it during season 3 is in episode 10
the Richter II and Morty date when Beth
mentions the future will be more like
season 1 making it seem like Beth knows
that she's inside a TV show then in the
post-credits tag there's the very direct
fourth wall break where he talks to the
audience about how long it's going to
take before season 4 gets here I might
have a big white Santa Claus beard what
I might do after season 4 airs is do
another separate video with all the
additional fourth wall breaks just for
those scenes but if you couldn't tell
the part of the promo where they reveal
all the episode titles for the five
episodes that are dropping before to the
end of the year not the entirety of
season 4 they're doing 10 episodes
during season 4 the five that we're
getting
just the ones that are happening before
Christmas they made the promo is a
parody on the stranger things season 3
promo that Netflix released teasing all
of their episode titles before season 3
started
so digging into the episode titles I'll
try to match some of these episode
titles with the references in the
footage that we've seen in the season 4
trailer but I'm assuming that the
episode titles are in chronological
order so episode 1 is the first title
they reveal episode 2 episode 3 so on so
forth but it starts with presumably
Season 4 episode 1 edge of tomorrow Rick
die repeat which is very clearly a
reference to edge of tomorrow live die
repeat that was a Japanese manga that
they adapted into the Tom Cruise movie
which most of you probably saw pretty
simple idea Tom Cruise gets stuck in a
time loop and has to defeat a group of
aliens to escape the time loop this
might correspond to the scenes with
Morty and chachi on that alien planet
episode 2 is the old man in the scene
clearly a reference to Ernst Hemingway
as the old man in the sea which is all
about this aging fisherman's battle with
his giant Marlin that he's trying to
capture because seat is literally in the
title that might correspond to the
scenes with Rick eating Arby's in the
special hover chair while Morty
complains about not being rated to climb
a cliff this difficult doing that big
Star Trek episode 5 parody episode 3-1
crew over the crew coos Morty is
obviously a reference to One Flew Over
the Cuckoo's Nest with Jack Nicholson
he's stuck in an insane asylum during
that movie but because of the flying
reference this might correspond to the
footage of summer and Beth fighting each
other like they're crazy on the airport
tarmac just like the Avengers fighting
each other during Captain America Civil
War also may be related to all the
meeseeks rioting in the streets episode
4 claw and hoarder special ricktum Morty
is obviously a reference to Law & Order
SVU
maybe we'll get another water tea iced
tea cameo because he seemed like he was
actually praising the show relatively
recently whereas when they originally
did the water tea get schwifty episode
he seemed like he really hated the idea
because he kind of sass them on Twitter
but that might have something to do with
the scenes of Morty fighting in a
security situation at the mall that they
describe in the footage maybe the scene
of him turning into the monster
maybe the scenes of them at the heist
convention stealing the ship that's also
connected to the ripoff Doctor Strange
scene then episode 5 rattle star Rick
lactic obviously a Battlestar Galactica
reference it's kind of hard to tell
which scenes from the trailer correspond
to the Battlestar episode nothing in
this trailer screams like it's from
Battlestar but they're all the Dungeons
& Dragons lookin scenes with them using
the improbability weapon from
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy to
transform their enemies into random
objects
there's the footage of them with gear
head inside Rick's spaceship there's
also the assassination classroom footage
of mr. poopy butthole fighting off his
students no idea which episode that
might happen in then there's also the
scene of Rick talking about slaying
dragons
I always slay Queen that doesn't really
correspond to any what these episode
titles might be so everybody let me know
in the comments which trailer scenes do
you think correspond to which of these
episode titles what'll happen is we're
only a couple of weeks away from the
season premiering so they'll probably a
little more footage that they'll drop
next week or maybe the week after that
then obviously all my episode videos
will probably wind up posting on Monday
morning just because the episodes air so
late at night but later tonight we have
a brand new Star Wars Episode nine
trailer dropping I'll do an Easter Egg
video for that as soon as they release
it leave all your video requests are big
questions you have about Rick and Morty
in the comments congratulations chase
losses you're the giveaway winner for my
last big Rick & Morty video please email
me on the about page of my channel so I
can get your contact details click here
for my Rick and Morty's season 4 trailer
Easter eggs and click here for my other
Rick and Morty season 4 teaser trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight